翻訳: Shiho Nakamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
むかし むかし
それほど遠くない村で
起きたことです
人間と神々が一緒に生活していた頃です
非常に不思議な時代でしたけれども
この日本の伝説の不思議な話を
まず 神々と一緒に生活していたことを
想像してみましょう
非常に素敵な話はいつでも聴ける
というのがまた素晴らしいでしょう
まあ きっと今日みたいな日
雪がいっぱい降り積もって
農作業ができないようなところでみんな
こうやって村の広場で集まって
いい話を聴こうじゃないか
という気持ちになった ような話ですね
神々と一緒に生活していた頃で
いい話をいっぱい聴きました
親子の関係 また 社会との関わり方
いろんないい話がありましたが
ある日突然神々はちょっと用があって
「天に帰らなきゃいけないのですよ」
という風に言ったら
広場で集まっていた人たちは
「なんで？」と思っていたのですけれど
「すぐ戻りますから 待っててね」
と言って
この広場のすみっこにあった
大木の上に登っていって
天に消えていきました
その時 神々がいなくなって
「どうしよう？」と思って
ずっと大木の下で待ってました
来ないな来ないなと思って
一日暮れました
また 「来ないな」と思って
次の日も暮れました
次の日から
ちょっとしばらく来ないなら
こんなつまんない思いをなんとかしよう
という風になって
神々から頂いた良いお話を
いっぱり語りました
それでも
この話を忘れては困るということで
いろんな形で これで
芸術が生まれたんですね
この良い話を歌にしたら
これを思い出しやすくなるんじゃないか
ということで
歌の誕生の話にもなるんですね
歌の始まり
また 踊りでそれを表現したら
それで 皆様に
伝えられるじゃないかということ
また演劇
それで神々の話を皆様に
分かち合えればいいな ということでした
この待っているところ
その大木の下で待っていたんですけれども
それが「まつのき」と
言うようになったんです
ずっと待ってましたから
それでいまだ この松の木は
必ず能舞台の鏡板（かがみいた）に
描くようになったのは
その伝説から始まったんですね
いまだ 歌舞伎や日本舞踊の舞台でも
時々見かけます
この松の木は
天と地を結ぶ象徴として
考えられていましたので
特に 能舞台の上で
人間と神々が交わっている
お能の話がいっぱい出ていますので
それで松の木が無いと[いけない]
必ず根っこが地について
上が天に昇っているところが
必要ですね
それで 少しずつ時間が経ってくると
私たちそれぞれ人類は
村から離れてしまって
それぞれの離れたところで
生活するようになると
今度は村が在って 広場が在って
木が在ったのが
この神聖なところに見立てて
家を建てるようになったんです
家が村のようになって
床の間を造って
その床の間が広場のようになって
その床の間の中で
長い年月待っていたことを象徴する
それぞれの季節の花を生けていました
また必ず 美しい掛け軸を飾って
この 神々と一緒に居た
理想的な美を思い起こすために
床の間ができました
しかし私たちはこれから生活が —
もっと[時代が]近くなってくると
例えば 西洋の文化の中で
人間と[神々]の関わりが
少しずつ変わってきました
もともと西洋でも東洋でも
生活の中に芸術は
ごく自然にあったので
「芸術」という言葉は
特に必要なかったんですけれども
私たちがこの19世紀の終わり頃
「芸術は芸術のため」という思想が
芸術から始まるようになったんですね
それはちょっと残念なことでした
なぜかと言うと
「芸術は芸術のため」というのは
「芸術は芸術家のため」
にもなってしまいました
なぜか私たちの生活の中で
神々の話が消えてしまって
芸術家だけの話になって
生活の中にあったアートが
なぜか美術館や画廊に
追いやられるようになってしまった
残念なことでした
実を言うと
10万年前の洞窟画
ブロンボスの洞窟画を観ると
ちゃんと生活を飾る
彩らせるようになっていたんですね
描いた人が大学に行って 美大に行って
学問で 資格がないとできない
みたいなことはなかったんですけれども
私たちは 「芸術は芸術のために」
という思想のために
忘れてしまったことが
いっぱいあります
なぜかわからないけれど
神々の話が消えてしまいました
じゃぁ 「神々の話」というのは
なんでしょうか？
気になりますよね
私たちがより社会の中で
円滑に生活できるようになるための
話だったと思います
ある意味
私たちがより良い人間になるために
誰に相談すればいいか考えると
おじいちゃん おばあちゃんの
話がありますね
なぜか 背後との繋がりを
象徴するところがあるんですね
私たちは 芸術を生活の中に
取り入れることによって
何が変わるでしょうか？
モダニズムの「芸術は芸術のため」
という発想から生まれてしまった
残念なことがいっぱいあるんですけれども
私たちが忘れたことは
例えば 純粋な美の交歓とは
何であるでしょうか？
また 芸術が私たちの感情に
もっとも直接的に伝わることを
忘れてしまったんじゃないか
芸術とは 思想や哲学の器にもなれる
芸術を通してエネルギーが伝わる
不思議なものもあります
私が 個人的に 特に絵描きとして
作品の中に込めるエネルギーは
僕が死んでからでも
皆様は作品を観ることによって
僕の込めたエネルギーに
アクセスできると思うと
非常に責任感が強くなります
この作品の中に込めたエネルギーは
ものすごくいい積極的な
ものでなければ
責任取れるのかな
と思って心配しています
また 芸術は心のよりどころにもなれる
私のおばあちゃんは
101歳まで生きていた方でしたけれども
非常に自立心の強い方で
また非常にセンスがいい人で
世界中あちこち生活してても
必ずアートを持って
住み家に飾ってました
人生の最後の頃になると
彼女は介護が必要になりまして
一人で生活することもできなくて
私たちと共に生活することも
難しくなりました
その頃 私たちは
彼女が入る施設の下見をしてた頃
非常に驚きました
こんなの生活の場と言うよりも
医療機関じゃないかという風に感じてて
まさに施設という言葉が
ふさわしいという感じでした
こういう冷たい無機質な空間で
おばあちゃんが
人生の終わりを過ごすなんて
という気持ちでした
私たちは彼女の好きな
ベッドカバーを敷いて
愛する孫たちの写真を飾っていても
良くなりませんでした
それで 「そっかぁ」と思って
彼女のおうちに走って帰って
好きだった絵の一枚を
部屋の中に飾るようにしていたら
非常に不思議な魔法が
あったんですね
おばあちゃんの部屋が
おばあちゃんのいつもの
おうちに早変わりしました
この奇跡は
アートの心のよりどころの効果
ではないかと思いました
その絵のところで人生を全うした
おばあちゃん —
いまだ作品を観るとき
おばあちゃんが
すぐそばにいるんじゃないかと
感じられるようになったんです
私たちは いにしえとの繋がりを
忘れてしまったのではないか
と思います
このいい話 —
私たちの先人たちから受けた
素晴らしい模範を
芸術によって思い起こされるの
ではないかと思います
それは「芸術は芸術家のため」
ということではなくて
私たち一人一人ものすごく
大事な話だと思います
最後に一言
こうやって老松もありますし
お能が大好きですから
皆様に 好きなお能のせりふを
ひとつ分かち合いたいと思います
これは『井筒』という曲のせりふです
「人の心の井戸の深さは
いまだ 知られていません」
いまだ 知られていない」
私たちはもともと 一人ひとり
みんな芸術家でもありました
この太古の芸術が生まれたところから
私たちが今まで来たところは
神々のいい話 有意義な話
ベッドで聴くような話も
どういう風に活かせるでしょうか
この物語の最後は
皆様に任せたいと思います
よろしくお願いします
（拍手）